cet adversaire c'est le monde de la
finance une partie de lui-même doit
savoir qu'il c'est un gros mensonge
22 janvier 2012 devant plus de dix mille
personnes réunies au bourget françois
hollande alors candidat socialiste à
l'elysée entre en campagne c'est un
françois hollande qui a été lui-même
surpris par l'ampleur de sa victoire
quelques mois plus tôt dans la primaire
au fond c'était dominique strauss-kahn
qui était prévu comme candidat et dsk a
fauté dans un hôtel à new york hollande
n'est pas une grande vedette de la
gauche et certains doivent se dire mais
mais au fond est-ce que c'est un vrai
homme de gauche veut vraiment
absolument aujourd'hui c'est vital et
pour rassembler il faut avoir recours
aux éternels marqueurs de la gauche
française il n'a pas de nom
pas de visage pas de partis
il ne présentera jamais sa candidature
il ne sera donc pas élu et pourtant ils
gouvernent et là il envoie le marqueur
c'est le monde de la finance ça y est
les gens leurs ennemis ils ont leur bouc
émissaire et les gens de gauche vont
pouvoir aller voter pour cet homme qui a
montré qu'il était un vrai homme de goût
on envie surtout en période de campagne
électorale de se faire plaisir même si
on se dit oh là là ça avec difficile de
régler son compte à la finance mais on
oublie ça et pendant un moment surtout
dans l'atmosphère d'un grand meeting à
on veut y croire il ya là quelque chose
allez disons le assez démagogique une
petite phrase démagogique qui va
poursuivre françois hollande pendant
tout son quinquennat on va découvrir
même peu à peu un premier né à président
baré public extrêmement pragmatique qui
va devenir de plus en plus socialiste
réformiste et même avec valse social
libéral et il va s'allier n'est bien sûr
les champs qui avaient cru que c'était
véritablement le candidat de lutte
contre la finance la gauche du parti
socialiste va
lui reprocher et ça va devenir le
phénomène des frondeurs nous avons saisi
sur le vif la réunion discrète voire
secrète de ce qu'on appelle les
frondeurs les frondeurs des
parlementaires socialistes ont désaccord
avec la politique économique de françois
hollande et des ministres qui leur
emboîtent le pas le phénomène des
frondeurs va devenir un phénomène massif
et va empêcher le président sortant de
se représenter j'ai décidé de ne pas
être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
il déclare forfait parce que quelque
part il a été prise en défaut par la
promesse qu'il avait faite cinq ans plus
tôt une petite phrase qui en cinq ans
est revenu comme un boomerang vers son
auteur et qui a marqué le début de la
ch'ti sion de la gauche
[Musique]